you wrote an article about meeting
former Clippers owner Donald sterling
for the first time and it gives you an
incredible insight into who this guy
really is yeah I am it was it was a
different experience he had you over to
his house party every year he has a
white party in Malibu and everybody has
to wear why if you don't wear why you
have to wear wow I gotta say when I won
but I first heard about the herbal tea
like he was having a white party I'm
like oh this has been going on for this
long he was so blatant about it so
everybody has to wear white and he shows
up in all black every time all black and
he's part yeah it says a lot about yeah
so he like this is I'm brand new to LA
like 20 years old and he introduces me
to everybody by the hand like he's he's
you know parading me around the party
with my hand in his hand like a grown
man just picture a grown man like like
walking behind like a 75 year old man I
was at the time but it was uh it was a
little it was a little weird and at one
point this guy just looked at me and
goes hey man you should keep smiling
it'll all be over soon
outside so idea they just kept smiling
yeah and he would say the same thing
every day what I love about the article
is he would lead you up to a group of
people introduce you and then ask you
the same questions each time like this
was a vaudeville act yeah it's like
we're it's like we rehearsed it you'd be
like everyone this is like Griffin he's
our new a newest star he was drafted
number one and I'd be like hey how you
doing and he'd be like and Blake where
are you from like Oklahoma and he'd be
like and what do you think about LA and
I'd be like oh it's you know it's cool
it's it's awesome and then he'd be like
and what about the girls in LA and I'd
be like oh they're cool too and then he
would just be like all right and grab my
hand
and then the same questions for the next
people oh yeah so if you happen to be in
like a different group and we you would
just have the same conversation now
let's talk about your new owners Steve
Ballmer he introduced himself with this
very fiery speech very energetic speech
and you guys responded to that you
responded to Steve bombers like
enthusiasm in his energy I mean we loved
it and it's it the thing about it is is
genuine it's not like he's just doing
this for a show it's jr. when he wants
he loves basketball he wants to win he's
I think he's always wanted to own a NBA
team and now he's had this opportunity
and that energy is contagious so we
embraced that yeah because I know that
some people online were taking his
enthusiasm and trying to chop it
together and sort of have fun with it
you guys wanted to make the point that
no no this is great
this is just what we need oh it's a
great thing and you know we're not gonna
we're not gonna hide it hide from that
and and not be proud of our owner
because because he's that way because
for a long time we had a guy I have in
white parties in Malibu
you